professor Klaus seller member of the
bail committee we are just heard at this
year's this year you are awarding the
discovery of checkpoint inhibitors could
you please explain what this is
well first of all this is a treatment
against cancer and it's a new principle
for treatment because unlike previous
treatments where you target the cancer
send these treatment targets the host
immune system the patient's immune
system and it does so by releasing or
blocking the brakes of the immune system
and when you release the brakes things
go faster and we have a strong response
against the patient's cancer cells one
of the laureates name's James Ellison
he has been mentioned there for a quite
a while how come with this you are
awarded the prize this is the time is
right the first approved the drug based
on this treatment it came in 2011
patients have been treated there for
several years now when we can see the
long-term outcome and it's very
convincing and we proceed with really a
big step in the fight against cancer
it was quite complicated different cells
and different receptors but in order to
describe this price in an accessible way
what kind of metaphor would you use I
would like to use the break metaphor the
brake pedal that you have on a car for
example where you can step on it and
everything stops and you can release it
and you get things going new what kind
of cancer treatment what cancer patients
can be treated using this method are
there any limits the most dramatic
responses are seen with the particular
type of skin cancer malignant melanoma
and I'm sure most viewers nobody sees
its pigmented cancer on the skin other
cancers that respond at least to PD one
treatment or line cancer and kidney
cancer and lymphoma and many other
cancers actually also so it will be very
exciting to see in the future exactly
how broad how broadly this can be
applied personally what makes you
enthusiastic by this price I myself am
an immunologist and I have actually
worked and to my knowledge for many many
years
there has been a lot of interesting new
discoveries in tumor immunology and
where we reveal basic mechanisms but
they were never sufficient to be able to
cure cancer in patients they were
sufficient to kill cancer in mice which
is somewhat easier and all the other
previous attempts to use the young
system such as vaccination or giving
cells they worked in some patients but
you could never generalize it to many
patients and this is what is different
about this one and it makes a big
difference for certain patients some
patients survive and are killed and some
patients get four years rather than one
year and that is quite no if we turn to
the laureates in James Ellison and
tasuku Pandu who are they I have met
them but I don't know either of them
very well but the professor allison is a
basic immunology sort trained in
medicine but in biology from the
beginning he became interested already
when he was a small boy and his father
gave me a chemistry kit and yes at the
splendid career in basic immunology he
made many important discoveries before
this one and he has been in many
different centers in the United States
Berkeley was mentioned here but he has
also been at the Memorial
sloan-kettering Cancer Center in New
York and in MD Anderson in excess
various now I'm also told that he plays
the harmonica in a blues band called the
checkmates the professor homeo is also
very distinguished basic immunology is
actually an md year so it says medicine
training but he has also contributed
very important discoveries in basic
immunology
before this one and he was not in cancer
immunology from the beginning
similar to demonism also was not in
casting
but these basic scientists made their
discoveries and persistently followed
them through and developed this
fantastic treatment step I'm not sure
whether professor from your place and
instrument but I know that he plays gold
and it's very interested in office when
they were doing this discovery whether
looking for this or was it a surprise
for them when they for professor Allison
I think he was working with the basic
regulation of the immune system like
many others and he did not discover the
molecule that he was working but he
realized its potential so he rapidly
tested an IV that nobody else tested I
don't know how expected it was for him
to get into cancer but he did because he
only I'm sure he did not think of cancer
at all in the beginning when he looked
and found his molecules he was doing
completely different things and actually
probably had ideas that he was doing
something completely different but as he
went on and he gradually revealed how
this biblical world
he understood with inspiration for
medicine how this one could add and even
become even more efficient and finally
and if you were to do an elevator pitch
on this price with the goal to simply
convey the overall concept in an
exciting way what would you say them
these scientists have discovered how you
can lock the brakes of the immune system
so that it goes much faster and act in a
much more intensive way and thus can
attack cancer cells so we can kill
cancer with
thank you very much thank you